yeah yeah oh I just have my on the
ceiling does it look her sound like I'm
gloating because I don't feel like I'm
gloating I'm just kinda celebrating I'm
just celebrating ticketing the light the
Ampera belite the glory of thousands of
youtube Ian's enjoy my music know what
this feels like it feels better than
this it feels better than a big stack of
$1 bills right now for the first time
ever a brotherhood 2.0 video after like
a hundred and fifty of these things is
on the front page of YouTube thank you
to whoever you are who put it there
and thank you to all the people who are
living such nice comments and also to
the people who are letting me know about
these really great porn sites oh where
would I find porn if it weren't for my
YouTube comments also lemme just plead a
little bit just a little bit of pleading
please stop posting spoilers in the
comments I know
we've read the book but not everybody
has they don't want to know if anything
in my song actually happens they don't
want to know what things I left out also
I bought the song for the book amount so
for the people who are asking me why I
didn't include certain things in the
book in the song it's because the song
doesn't have spoilers in it the song is
just a song they wrote before the book
came out stop posting spoilers and that
concludes this special edition of
brotherhood 2.0 for more brotherhood 2.0
videos please visit Brotherhood to.com
thank you we appreciate your patronage
kitty how listen to the PIRs